et tu fais ça très simplement tu écoutes
ce que j'ai dit et puis tu répètes après moi
oui on y va
alors oh non Oh duo d'infirmières
duo bouddhiste tres dos uno due tre
Quattro Cinque quelle semaine attends six les
élèves ici qui sont de la multi
école ils'  Je suis très interactif et même
s'ils apprennent encore l'anglais,
ils sont très enthousiastes et enthousiastes à l'idée de poser
des questions pour communiquer à la fois avec
moi-même et avec les professeurs. Ils vont faire la
fête. Ils ont la sixième année dans le
commerce pour prouver qu'ils ont un logiciel de niveau supérieur.
Ils ont développé un circuit compétent.
Avella à Agra bâton un de métal nano 7
de Conchas jamais rempli énorme sur ce régal
visuel le 17 Busan
bleu Hôpital Doce de Jose si bemol
étudiant bienvenue Tony met le
plus grand collectionneur d'électro jeunes
enfants de tous une
pierre géniale mal en colère raide Penina donc  rapide
Ashley dans un roman mémo une
évolution de Chanela un Monsieur c'est un
partisan juif de l'ordinateur kanji avoir
exceller dans le futur extra plus facilement est
possible au dactylographe du moulin
[Applaudissements]